un intento simbólico de consagrar el
derecho al aborto una ley federal que
terminó en fracaso los demócratas sabían
que no alcanzarían los 60 votos
necesarios para avanzar hacia una
votación final en el senado de 100
miembros
de mociones norwich en los 50
republicanos más el demócrata de
virginia occidental joe manchin
rechazaron el miércoles la ley de
protección de la salud de la mujer sabe
lamentablemente el senado no defendió el
derecho de la mujer a tomar decisiones
sobre su propio cuerpo lo que estamos
viendo en este país son líderes
republicanos y extremistas que buscan
criminalizar y castigar a las mujeres
por tomar decisiones sobre su propio
cuerpo making
el presidente joe biden dijo en twitter
que no dejaría de luchar para proteger
el acceso a la atención reproductiva de
las mujeres se unió a kamala harris para
instar a los votantes a considerar sus
prioridades al emitir sus votos en las
elecciones de medio término el tema
profundamente polarizador del aborto
parece destinado a dominar la campaña
esta no es la ley de protección de la
salud de la mujer es la ley del aborto
ha pedido sin restricciones sin
limitaciones promueve el aborto a una
escala mucho más allá de roberts bites y
mucho más allá de lo que la gran mayoría
de los estadounidenses se sienten
incómodos
la tormenta política se produce después
de que un borrador de opinión filtrado
sugiriera que los jueces conservadores
de la corte suprema podrían revocar a
finales de junio el fallo histórico de
hace 50 años si lo hacen el aborto
podría prohibirse o restringirse en
aproximadamente 26 estados liderados por
republicanos